[Music]
I have returned how I make video help
that's right everybody I have returned
after one month of long break I am back
I broke my 10 year streak of daily
uploads to go on at one month break to
do I haven't done much it's been nice
actually
boy oh boy has there been a lot of
confusion wait first I did so much to
address I don't even know where to start
well getting to everything everything
every little detail first of all what I
said in my last video I know I'm making
this a bigger thing than it is goddamn
do I look scruffy Jesus Christ Oh God I
still do although hey that's a good
first update beard all right
there's beard now we're gonna have to
get used to this that's fine sure
everyone will comment about it anyway if
there better not be something huge meme
happening while I'm gone okay
you know since I was in Japan during the
time of the thingy I bought about three
boxes of these I was like it's gonna
happen I'm gonna die not on my watch not
gonna happen
sigh night ting trough which funds
you'll buy late I've been prepared that
is dab if stabbings Davin is still cool
right all right let's get into this
video
sigh Barry kindly prepared a folder
called tears returned and he starts off
by adding this in there thank you sighs
it's not even real like if it was real
ever I understand like why did you add
this I'm just kidding I appreciate this
folded this is great
still not as good as Japanese toilets
okay the biggest disappointment of all
time coming back from Japan every time
every time I sit on the toilet here the
disappointment hits you it hits your
buttocks it's cold and it doesn't spray
and you have to wipe and you realize
that you're the Savage and they are the
elves just like the Lord of the Rings
okay so what is this cooking I'm not
reading that the leaf gardening general
painting what is this what have you guys
been up to
PewDiePie submissions is now the biggest
Lego subreddit and they go sub predict
nothing too freaky that's actually kinda
cute you know I always wondered what you
guys would do I think I said it if what
if I snuffed it randomly what if Corona
Chan got me you know what's gonna happen
to the subreddit then well now we know
absolute garbage thank you okay this is
the top voted meme out of the entire
break there's just bound to be some
really good memes cardi what they see on
your mind
Zander it's freakin weird that in order
to go to sleep you have to pretend like
you are already sleeping oh my god my
mind blown does this look cool dot shape
or you know what you can joke about
stuff right yeah I remember you can joke
about stuff we're cool another thing
that will blow your mind even further
and I thought about this while I was in
the break when you close your eyes I
don't know why I never thought of this
your eyes are still there okay
I thought for some reason they go up in
your head or something you're still
looking even with your eyes is closed
you're always looking even when you're
asleep you're looking what's on your
mind huh I'm never taking a break again
PC gets 4k console gets 4k mobile gets
4k security cameras yeah generally you
don't need to see the face of the people
on security cameras though this is
understandable this is actually the
footage from when my Japanese house got
robbed I like this by the way hey I'm
back from a break so Felix whatever you
do memes
let's just keep jumping to the memes for
Michigan men arrested for driving a
horse and a buggy while drunk how do you
drive a horse who wrote this no New York
Post excellent
they look like villagers in Shrek the
Chad quad Chad quad Chad quad what you
gonna do what you gonna do when they
ride a horse and buggy at you imagine
you're Prince Harry and move to Canada
every time you reach in your wallet you
reminded that your grandma is pissed at
you damn she does look very angry son
you absolute [ __ ] had what are you doing
thinking of an idea for a meme realizing
that I needed to edit the template and
add an extra panel realizing that I can
post a third panel for my friend nice
that's a nice mean well done good job
you peepee what was I saying there was
something I used to say pee pee pee pee
yes
the ancient peepee what was it what was
it ancient people I'm a Boomer humor I
hate my wife millennial humor I my life
Chansey humor eating clock is very time
consuming
boomer wife bad millennial life bad bra
life Brad PT 5 comes back from break the
entire subreddit what is this you've
been doing gardening is this why there's
gardening there's links they dams I put
effort thank you Sam Felix is probably
checking the sub rate right now and he
is confused the hell is this I said I I
think I understand but I still don't
understand does that make sense I think
that makes sense
when you don't use reddit for a week and
start seeing all the cooking and
gardening
what now it's Lego now what that you
change take me o me I'll put in garden
themed memes great high number neighbor
Ohio law that's a reddit meme right
you're a redditor prove it yeah you're a
redditor you better be ready to prove it
it's gardening week ladies and gents
please it's like a week what is this god
I feel old
I leave the internet for a month when it
February imputes hasn't come back guess
our garden it's February around I'm back
come on that's one garden girl I would
garden my I would just gar I would
garden with her what do you think I
would say this realizing they made it
gardening week in the middle of winter
yeah big brain the zoom it's pretty much
what I expect at this point by my
audience gardening week oh my god spent
lunch my crap oh god I don't remember
oh man hell Oh guys I'm gonna need some
video requests by the way since I'm back
I don't
I don't know how to fell don't know when
it's finally gardening week but you see
no memes about it I'm not seeing enough
gardening yeah yeah and red hair for a
while I was weird you guys seen the hot
takes that ninjas been doing lately the
phrase it's just a game it's such a weak
mindset the phrase is just a game is
such a weak mindset you are okay with
what happened losing imperfection of a
craft when you stop getting angry after
losing you've lost twice there's also
something to learn and always room to
for improvement never settle me playing
Nintendogs ever use the excuse it's just
a game I'm gonna lose my mind imagine
telling LeBron James Tom Brady that way
hey my dude telling LeBron James is this
a game what are your emotions about
losing the finals now god autopen did a
voiceover it's so good Kaiba it's just a
game the phrase it's just a game it's
such a weak mindset you are okay with
what happened
losing imperfection of a craft when you
stop getting angry after losing you've
lost twice so good oh my god Twitter
ah I hate Twitter damn I watch you here
recently it's so good I might make a
video on it cuz I love it so much I
never seen yogi oh I don't know why who
is that gardener is that goal or a Borg
I bought forgot my own memes at this
point help me how I'm entering this new
week with all my gardening memes amazing
good job so what was cooking week then
oh my god that looks delicious that
actually looks really good and I don't
even like cakes since our cooking has
1.5 million users and rp2 five
submissions had 2.5 million we're the
biggest cooking subreddit Oh
why water what a feat ha ha got you oh
wait how do you do the whoa did I do it
right
I think I did right that's what kids do
now I've been practicing in front of
them there that's pretty good size edit
that so that looks cool okay peers
coming back from his break what's going
on here
breakfast you better stop this now that
I'm back okay from now on is this gonna
be changes here we're not calling it
love Y anymore we're calling it let Y
like the fringe so it can no longer be
confused with Y what was painting an art
week is that a pie huh or what is that I
don't know what that is
hey we got fan art some good old fan it
that's awesome
Hugo Lauder very nice Hey all right some
arts and crafts that looks sick that's
exid really cool Joss amine because
hand-drawn memes seem to get a lot of
votes everyone looking at my yard it's
evolving just backwards
you mean devolving Felix devolving it is
a word idiot look how my ineptitude
becomes memes very nice eh oh okay a
very artsy very crafty me three days
without Felix everything hurts and I'm
dying it's weird it's been so long now
is anyone even gonna care is that it
what even gonna care that I'm back let's
read some nice comments PewDiePie I'll
be back soon
last online eight years ago PewDiePie
I'll be back soon
Sven still cool it's people making the
same joke over and over huh Peter pie
hello guys I broke my mind a lot
everyone has come back to this video
just to check if cutie pie come back yet
technically I won't have to come back
like I could probably retire if I wanted
to so it was good for me to take a break
to sort of process what I'm doing and
what I want what I want to do in the
future and there's definitely some
changes I will have to do with the
channel I think but I'll I'll do them
gradually and I don't want to just like
say okay now we're doing this I just
think I've been obsessing too much about
YouTube and just like pushing myself way
too hard for too long when it's
like all right well there's other stuff
I want to do as well and I'm working on
some bigger project as well which I
don't want to limit myself to just doing
daily just for the sake of it although I
have been missing it a lot
it's funny I actually thought I wouldn't
be able to go on a break I thought oh
maybe I'm so addicted to YouTube that I
will just be crawling on the walls and
be like oh god I need to turns out no I
I'm not sure decide it was completely
fine to be fair I was in Japan it was
easy to distract myself but at the same
time yeah that was definitely days where
I'm like huh it made me appreciate the
fact that I have an audience I kind of
just taken that for granted in a way I'm
sorry and I think I've only seen all the
negative parts of having an audience
just because my following became so big
that I just got really tired of
constantly and asked being asked for
stuff on the PM from people in the
street and all that but surprisingly I
got a lot of a lot of secret words that
recognized me that was really nice for
those who don't know we have a secret
word now in case you meet me you have to
say the secret phrase I think almost
half people said it so that make made me
feel good day 36 Pierce is still gone I
begun to talk to myself I'm thinking go
and man I don't feel 9 anymore I feel
earlier well you are he ain't coming
back is he
well you guys have really given up huh
it's funny there's been so much
speculation I haven't said anything when
I'm coming back or how long it's gonna
take this I'll be right back is
something my dad told me okay all right
ty I make videos liar oh sorry
we found them what is this oh my god
there they are guys I gotta go on a
break I gotta go to an article right
freaking now for no reason
add a whole leg me mr. one meme that
keeps on living huh it's painting week
you paint a meme it gets to up votes
congratulations that looks absolutely
horrendous I'm sorry small peepee oh
yeah that's right baby I'm kidding I'm
kidding
inconclusive pee pee this subreddit you
can't post Lego memes it's still
painting week me and intellectual Wow
it's Bob Lego loss missing Felix
condition
berg last seen 15th of january damn leg
away damn
alright alright I respect that I respect
leggo weak military tanks heart shape
for Russian soldier proposal that's the
true weapon nice oh my god you
stone-cold murderer hey now there's like
a week I can finally pose this custom
when I made that's kind of fun with the
theme maybe we should do more of that
maybe you guys say I didn't have it all
god I take it back take it back stop
stop what is the biggest it's a ball big
just backwards damn I miss memes how
about that I never thought I would say
that who just won't get this baby
platypus Perry the [ __ ] this is my
sub Riddick my rules and I will get it
okay I don't get it
it's fine I don't care anyway alright
daily content back at it again I will
try at least I don't know we'll see
thank you for all the nice and lovely
supportive comments while I was gone
that really cheered me up I really
appreciate that I think it's been really
healthy and good for me to take this
break and I appreciate everyone's
patience while I was gone I didn't
haven't posted anything anywhere and it
was very really nice to do that I think
you can tell just how tired and
frustrated I was in this video it's just
like it was it was necessary there was
necessary but that's it for me for now
see you guys hey boy hey smile oh yes
much like and also subscribe because
apparently like 68% of you are
subscribed what
and I'd say bye-bye